aber auf der Regierungsbank da hat schon
Platz genommen und das soll ja der erste
Tagesordnungspunkt sein wie schon
angedeutet die Befragung der
Bundesregierung mit
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach der sich hier eine Stunde
lang sie sehen ihn hier von der Regie
schön eingefangen der sich eine Stunde
lang eine gute Stunde lang hier den
Abgeordneten
den Fragen der Abgeordneten stellen wird
er darf zu Beginn einen 5-minütigen
einleitungsvortrag halten
zu einem Thema aus seinem Ressort und
sie haben wir hören mal den
Bundesminister Karl Lauterbach
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst mal
lassen Sie mich beginnen mit der
corona-situation wir sind am Beginn
einer herbst- und winterwelle die es
kommt nicht überraschend wir sind aber
auf dieser Welle sehr gut vorbereitet
wir haben zunächst einmal im Rahmen der
Beschaffung von angepassten Impfstoffen
Impfstoffe beschaffen die auf die
Varianten mit denen wir derzeit zu
ringen haben gut vorbereitet sind sodass
die Versicherten eine Auswahl haben
zwischen entsprechenden angepassten
Impfstoffen wir haben darüber hinaus die
den panamerader eingeführt der pandemera
da erlaubt es den Ländern präzise zu
erkennen wie die jeweilige Situation in
ihren Ländern ist so dass sie relativ
früh reagieren können wir haben für die
besonders moderatenen Gruppen
Arzneimittel beschäftigt die
Sterblichkeit der Patienten deutlich
senken können diese Arzneimittel sind in
den Pflegeeinrichtungen
gelagert worden werden dort gelagert und
können durch Hausärzte direkt abgegeben
werden so dass wir dort eine deutlich
verbesserte Versorgung der Patienten
erwarten können und schließlich haben
wir mit dem Infektionsschutzgesetz was
wir über den Sommer vorbereitet haben
die Länder in die Lage versetzt auf der
Grundlage der vorhandenen Daten
entsprechend infektionsschutzmaßnahmen
vorzunehmen insbesondere die
maskenpflicht in den Innenräumen
einzuführen aber auch wenn das notwendig
wäre diese auszudehnen wenn es ganz
schlimm käme sogar in Außenbereichen
aber davon gehen wir derzeit nicht aus
ich appelliere an die Länder die also
Verantwortung auch wahrzunehmen wir
sehen derzeit stark steigende Fallzahlen
ich höre aber dass die Länder diese
Maßnahmen auch derzeit kontrollieren bzw
diskutieren ich gehe daher mit einem
Freund ich gehe daher von einem
verantwortungsvollen Handeln gehe ich
aus zum zweiten die Krankenhäuser sind
an der Situation wo Sie also mit
steigenden Energiekosten insbesondere
Stromkosten aber auch Gas konfrontiert
sind darüber hinaus ist Inflation
stärker als das was die
landesbasiswahlwerte an zusätzlichen
Einnahmen erwarten lassen darauf werden
wir reagieren indem wir im Rahmen
unseres 200 Milliarden schutzpaketes die
Länder in die Lage versetzen werden die
Krankenhäuser zu unterstützen die
Krankenhäuser auch direkt unterstützen
und schließlich möchte ich darauf
hinweisen wir haben ein Finanz eine
Finanzlücke von 17 Milliarden in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung das
werden wir in den nächsten Wochen durch
das finanzstabilisierungsgesetz werden
das Ausgleichen wir sind am Vorabend
wichtiger Gesetze und ich will hier nur
numerisch ganz kurz zusammenfassen dass
wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
insgesamt also 12 Gesetze ans Netz
bringen werden die wir dann mit Ihnen
diskutieren werden wir werden für die
Kinderheilkunde die wahlpauschalen
überwinden bei der Versorgung von
Kindern erwäsischer Schritt nach vorn
wir werden der Geburtshilfe zur Lösungen
kommen dass die Geburtshilfe auf dem
Land sichergestellt werden kann wir
werden Tages-
nicht übernachten müssen wo dieses
medizinisch nicht notwendig ist wir
werden das diad System weiterentwickeln
so dass auch vorhaltepauschalen
berücksichtigt werden können so dass die
Krankenhäuser besser dort platziert sind
wo auch der Bedarf ist im Rahmen der
Digitalisierung haben wir zwei
Schwerpunkte die elektronische
Patientenakte wird als ob artakter
eingeführt wir werden darüber hinaus
auch das e-rezept also etwas anders
organisieren nach vorne bringen
gesundheitskioske als Siebte Maßnahme
werden in den besonders benachteiligten
Städten und Stadtteilen die Versorgung
ergänzen wir werden durch das
Krankenpflege entlastungsgesetz die
Pflegekräfte deutlich entlasten und wir
werden darüber hinaus also auch für die
Langzeitpflege eine Finanzierungsreform
vorschlagen die die also Langzeitpflege
sicherstellt die unabhängige
Patientenberatung wird das durch das
upd-gesetz also verbessert wir werden
eine Gesetzgebung zur Legalisierung von
Cannabis also vorstellen wo insbesondere
der Gesundheitsschutz im Vordergrund
steht so dass Cannabis tatsächlich so
konsumiert werden kann dass diejenigen
die es konsumieren gesichert sind und
dass der Gesundheitsschutz beim
Cannabiskonsum im Vordergrund steht es
geht ja nicht um die Ausweitung des
Konsums und schließlich werden wir
Gesetze vorstellen wo wir die
psychotherapeutische Versorgung
verbessern und zwar sowohl in den
Krankenhäusern wie auch im ambulanten
Bereich also 12 gesetzliche Grundlagen
die wir derzeit vorbereiten ich freue
mich auf die Diskussion dieser wichtigen
Gesetze mit Ihnen
vielen Dank wir beginnen die
regierungsbefragung zu den einleitenden
Ausführungen des Bundesministers Herrn
Dr Karl Lauterbach und zum
Geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzung und mit
allgemeinen Fragen
schon mal prophylaktisch vorab der erste
Fragesteller oder die erste
Fragestellerin hat jeweils eine Minute
sowohl für die Frage und der Minister
hat dann jeweils eine Minute für die
Antwort also immer auf die Zeit achten
und für die Nachfrage allerdings nur 30
Sekunden jeweils will das nur schon mal
vorab sagen damit alle noch mal
wissen wie das Verfahren hier gleich ist
das Wort hat zuerst als erster
Fragesteller der Kollege Tino Sorge aus
der cdu/cd CSU-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesgesundheitsminister
zahlreiche Kliniken Pflegeheime und
Arztpraxen sind durch die Inflation von
fast 10 Prozent und massiv gestiegene
Energiepreise in ihrer existenzgefährdet
sie haben es gerade eben noch mal
angesprochen die Bundesregierung weist
seit Monaten von dieser Thematik
unternimmt aber leider nichts dagegen
Insolvenzen und Schließungen drohen
bereits deshalb würde mich konkret
interessieren wann genau kommt endlich
das Rettungspaket für die
Infrastrukturen Gesundheitswesen aus dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium
die vielen Dank für die Frage die
Grundlage für die Abschätzung wie groß
der Bedarf in den Krankenhäusern ist ist
er jetzt am Wochenende geschaffen worden
weil wir durch das allgemeine
Rettungspaket jetzt einen Fahrplan haben
wie wir die Energiekosten in Deutschland
Bremsen werden davon werden auch die
Krankenhäuser profitieren da werden aber
dann wahrscheinlich noch restbelastungen
und verbleiben wie diese restbelastungen
ausgeglichen werden wird derzeit von
meinem Haus vorbereitet ich bin
diesbezüglich auch in direkten
Verhandlungen mit Finanzminister Lindner
und wir werden somit Ihnen unmittelbar
vortragen aber wir haben hier drei
Blöcke wir haben im Prinzip die
steigenden Gaskosten die Stromkosten und
den inflationsbereich der durch also die
steigende
landesbasisfall wird Veränderungen nicht
abgedeckt ist und wir werden alle drei
Bereiche werden wir entsprechend
abfedern
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
vielen Dank Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister das sind ja im
Grunde das was sie seit Monaten tun im
Grunde nur Ankündigungen deshalb würde
mich interessieren wir haben bereits im
April darauf hingewiesen ich habe ihn
bereits im April dazu auch ein Schreiben
auch im mit Blick auf die wirklich
kritische Situation in den Kliniken
geschickt wir haben als Union vor der
Sommerpause diesbezüglich schon einen
Antrag eingebracht und deshalb würde
mich jetzt interessieren von ihnen warum
ihr Haus bisher untätig geblieben ist
und keine konkreten Maßnahmen vorgelegt
hat ich habe ja gerade also ausgeführt
dass die Voraussetzungen für die
Berechnung der Bedarfe in den
Krankenhäusern ist am Wochenende
geschaffen wurde indem wir uns eben auf
das also Schutzpaket beziehen und dort
lässt sich dann abschätzen wie hoch die
Mehrbedarfe für die sozialen
Einrichtungen sind das ist ja auch in
dem Papier der Expertenkommission genau
beschrieben somit wir haben das Papier
jetzt am Wochenende bekommen und ich
bitte daher um Nachsicht dass ich nicht
schon vor Monaten dieses Ergebnis
vorwegnehmen konnte
gibt es zu diesem Thema weitere
Nachfragen Kollege pilsinger
ja Bundesminister die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft hat in dieser
Woche ja auch deutlich gemacht dass die
Vorschläge der gaspreiskommission hinten
und vorne nicht ausreichen um die
Krankenhäuser zu entlasten zwei Drittel
der ungedeckten Kosten sei nicht
aufgrund der Energiekosten sondern doch
Kostensteigerung bei den
Medizinprodukten Arzneimitteln
Lebensmitteln und Dienstleistungen
entstanden wie werden sie denn
sicherstellen dass unsere Krankenhäuser
nicht unter dieser Kosten Last
zusammenbrechen und deswegen noch mal
die Frage bis wann wollen Sie den
Gesetzesvorschlag einbringen da es kein
zeitlichen Verzug mehr geben darf bei
der Stabilisierung unserer Krankenhäuser
ich hatte ja eben selbst eingeräumt dass
die Vorschläge der Kommission nicht
ausreichen um das Delta komplett zu
beseitigen ich hob darauf ab dass die
inflationskosten die Differenz zwischen
der Entwicklung der Landesbasisfallwerte
und das also in medizinischen Inflation
also gesch eigene Krankenhäusern
abgedeckt werden muss ich hatte darauf
hingewiesen dass ich in Gesprächen mit
Finanzminister Lindner diesbezüglich
sind wenn der Mehrbedarf ist bekannt und
der Mehrbedarf wird auch mit der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft und
mit einzelnen Kliniken im Detail
besprochen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen wenn
Sie möchten muss aber nicht
noch nicht beantwortet bis wann sie das
Gesetz vorlegen wollen das war meine
Frage und deswegen die bitte ob Sie eine
zeitliche Einschätzung bringen können
bis wann sie es machen wollen
ja das kann ich wir werden das
rechtzeitig machen
gibt es zum Thema Krankenhaus und
Energiekosten steigen noch eine Frage
Minister
wenn ich bald etwas passiert wird es zu
einer kalten Strukturreform kommen
Rehakliniken Pflegeeinrichtungen und
Praxen werden schließen
Versorgungsengpässe für breite
Bevölkerungsschichten drohen mich würde
interessieren wie genau soll ein
Rettungsschirm aussehen und noch mal
gefragt diese Aussage reicht mir
eigentlich nicht ganz was die zeitliche
Situation und Schiene betrifft wann soll
er kommen
ich will es bereits darauf hin dass die
Gespräche mit
Finanzminister Lindner bereits begonnen
haben und in der nächsten Woche
fortgesetzt werden dass wir auf das
Ergebnis der Expertenkommission am
Sonntag warten mussten eine Abschätzung
des Mehrbedarfs vorher nicht möglich war
auch die Ergebnisse der
Expertenkommission müssen jetzt erst
einmal in gesetzgeberische Maßnahmen
übersetzt werden so dass wir parallel in
der Vorbereitung dieser
gesetzgeberlichen Maßnahmen für den
Energiebedarf insgesamt bereits im
Krankenhaussektor mit abdecken wir haben
das voll im Blick und wir werden das
rechtzeitig machen das war keine
polemische Bemerkung sondern ich bin mit
den Krankenhäusern im engen Austausch
auch mit dem Präsidenten oder mit dem
Geschäftsführer der
Krankenhausgesellschaft und daher können
sich darauf verlassen ich habe ja sehr
früh auf dieses Thema hingewiesen wir
haben das im Blick und werden das lösen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
deswegen Dank Herr Minister eine
Nachfrage teilen Sie die Einschätzung
der Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft
dass sich die
Finanzierungslücke bei Sachkosten und
Energie auf rund 15 Milliarden Euro in
diesen und im kommenden Jahr summiert
können Sie das Abschätzen bitte diese
Einschätzung kann ich nicht teilen weil
das würde ja bedeuten dass ich in der
Lage wäre die Entwicklung der Preise für
zum Beispiel Gas und Strom im nächsten
Jahr vorherzusehen dazu bin ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht in der
Lage und ich bin auch nicht ganz sicher
ob die Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft
dazu in der Lage ist
so ich sehe dazu keine weiteren
Nachfragen
[Musik]
Frau Zöllner sie dürfen
nicht stell liebe Kollegen die Frage
nicht noch mal anders lieber Herr
Minister mir geht es auch noch ein paar
darum um das Thema Energie und das ist
zum Beispiel für die ambulanten
Pflegedienste natürlich ganz konkret im
ländlichen Raum des Thema der
Spritpreise was planen sie da in dem
Bereich auch darauf haben wir schon vor
Monaten hingewiesen und deswegen die
Frage was wird konkret für die
ambulanten
Pflegedienste da vorgesehen im Bereich
des Sprits was ja sozusagen deren
wichtigstes Instrument ist um von A nach
B mit beispielsweise dem Auto zu kommen
ja in der Tat vielen Dank für diese
Frage Frau Abgeordnete sowohl für die
stationären Pflegeeinrichtungen wie auch
für die ambulanten Pflegedienste ergeben
sich Mehrkosten die durch die jetzigen
Verträge die ja oft auch langfristigerer
Natur sind nicht abgedeckt sind daher
planen wir dort die Möglichkeit die
Verträge kurzfristige anzupassen so dass
die zusätzlichen Kosten es sind ja nicht
nur
Benzinkosten sondern sind auch andere
Kosten dazu gekommen sind dass diese
umgelegt werden können also es muss auf
jeden Fall gewährleistet sein durch eine
Verkürzung der jeweiligen
Vertragsabschlüsse dass die also
Mehrkosten weitergegeben werden können
an die Pflegekassen und die
Refinanzierung bei den Pflegekassen
refinanziert dann das data
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank und auch hier die Frage weil
das natürlich zeitlich einfach alle
unter Druck stehen wann rechnen Sie
damit zeitlich ganz konkret für ein
Signal für die ambulanten Pflegedienste
gerade in den ländlichen Räumen
für die also stationäre Versorgung haben
wir ja die verkürzte Vertrags also
Geltung bereits beschlossen im Kabinett
mit der also wohngeldreform die die
Pflege mit abdeckt Wohngeld Plus oder
das dort kurzfristig diese Zusatzkosten
weitergegeben werden können eine
ähnliche Regelung für die ambulanten
Dienste ist in Vorbereitung
bevor ich die nächsten Nachfrage Aufrufe
ich will noch mal erinnern zum gleichen
Thema wir waren ursprünglich beim
Krankenhaus und den Energiekosten jetzt
sind wir schon ausgeweitet auf die
ambulanten Dienste aber jetzt bitte bei
diesem Thema bleiben damit wir die
anderen Fragen auch noch berücksichtigen
können das als nächstes hat das Wort ich
glaube der Kollege Reichert aus der
afd-fraktion
bis da ich habe ebenfalls eine Frage im
Bereich der ambulanten Pflegedienste
es haben etliche Bürger mir mitgeteilt
dass sie Informationen ihrer
entsprechenden Pflegedienstleister
erhalten haben das aufgrund der
steigenden Energiekosten
gegebenenfalls zum Beispiel statt bisher
vier Stunden Pflegeleistung pro Woche
nur noch drei Stunden und ähnliches
erbracht werden können meine Frage dazu
haben Sie
Informationen darüber in welchem Umfang
das geschieht wie sehen sie diese
Situation und was planen Sie um hier den
Bürgern Sicherheit zu geben
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter für diese
Frage zunächst einmal also eine
Verkürzung der Pflege Leistungen
einseitig durch den Pflegedienst ist
natürlich nicht erlaubt und ist mir auch
nicht bekannt das wäre ja auch ein Bruch
mit den geltenden Regeln und dann würde
sich die Frage stellen ob der
Pflegedienst dann die Leistung noch so
erbracht hat dass sie überhaupt
abgerechnet werden können grundsätzlich
haben Sie aber recht dass wir mit
Mehrbelastungen in der ambulanten Pflege
zu rechnen haben und daher habe ich eben
schon bei der Frage von der Abgeordneten
Zahlen darauf hingewiesen dass wir die
Verkürzung der Vertragslaufzeiten
zwischen Pflegekassen und Pflegediensten
planen so dass die Mehrkosten
weitergegeben werden können an die
Pflegekassen und dass wir diese dann
refinanzieren im Rahmen der Maßnahmen
die ich eben angesprochen habe
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ich
gehe also davon aus dass sie ich nehme
aus ihren Aussagen dass Sie
sicherstellen dass es durch die erhöhten
Kosten im Bereich der Pflege nicht zu
einem Rückgang der Pflegequalität der
Menschen vor Ort kommt genau davon gehe
ich raus ich gehe davon aus dass die
Pflegequalität nicht senken wird obwohl
wir in dieser Krisensituation sind weil
wir die Leistungen so finanzieren werden
dass sie in der Qualität erbracht werden
können wie sie bisher erbracht worden
von daher gehe ich nicht davon aus dass
wir einen Einbruch oder ein Absinken der
Pflegequalität weder im ambulanten noch
im stationären Sektor haben
Nachfrage aus der SPD-Fraktion die
Kollegen baradari zum gleichen Thema
frau Präsidentin genau zu dem Thema Herr
Minister vielen herzlichen Dank für ihre
Ausführung für die Investitionskosten
der Krankenhäuser sind die Länder
zuständig und in vielen Ländern sind da
keine Investitionen getätigt worden auch
in Hinblick darauf was Gebäudesanierung
oder erneuerbare Energien angeht könnten
sie uns vielleicht darstellen wo noch
Verbesserungsbedarf bundesweitig aber
vor allen Dingen in der Zuständigkeit
der Länder vielleicht auch in Bezug auf
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bordeaux und dort
noch Verbesserungsbedarf ist ja vielen
Dank Frau Abgeordnete für diese Frage in
der Tat ist es so dass die Länder seit
vielen Jahren ihren Investitionskosten
nicht nachkommen das hat zur Folge dass
zum Teil die Heizkosten deutlich höher
sind als sie sonst sein müssten weil die
Heizanlagen zum Teil veraltet und
ineffizient sind von der Dämmung der
also Gebäude ganz abzusehen somit sind
die Gebäude im Sommer zu heiß und im
Winter zu kalt und müssen entsprechen
Kapital zu werden wir werden jetzt noch
viele Gelegenheiten haben mit den
Ländern über dieses Defizit zu
verhandeln zunächst im Rahmen der
Umsetzung des also entlastungspaketes
welches ich eben angesprochen habe für
welches wir die Kommissionsvorschläge am
Wochenende bekommen haben da wird es
viele Verhandlungen mit den Ländern
geben was sind die Verpflichtungen der
Länder wir werden aber auch im Rahmen
der von mir eben angesprochenen
krankenhausgesetze diese Gelegenheit
haben ich hatte ja darauf hingewiesen
dass wir das fahrpauschalsystem
überwinden wollen bei der
Kinderheilkunde wir wollen die
Geburtshilfe also besser abdecken wir
wollen die fahrpauschalen so verändern
dass also wir stationäre Aufenthalt da
wo nicht nötig nicht erbracht werden
muss und dass derg-system das
fahrpauschalensystem insgesamt
verbessern somit wir werden über viele
Monate jetzt mit den Ländern verhandeln
und bei diesen Gelegenheiten immer
wieder auch über die Investitionszusagen
und Verpflichtungen der Länder
verhandeln können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Dank ich wüsste ganz gerne ob es das
spezielle Gespräche gibt auch mit dem
Gesundheitsminister Herr Laumann in NRW
als das bevölkerungsreichste Bundesland
interessiert es mich natürlich auch als
Abgeordnete aus dem Land sehr
an der Tat ist also auch dass Bundesland
nach der Nordrhein-Westfalen den
Verpflichtungen nicht nachgekommen
sind aus früheren Gesprächen ist mir das
bekannt diese Defizite bekannt und
bisher habe ich aber von ihm nicht
gehört wie er diesen Verpflichtungen
begegnen möchte
vielen Dank ich habe noch eine Nachfrage
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE zum gleichen
Thema Kollege
Göppinger vielen vielen Dank ist besitzt
auf die Antwort auf die auf die Ebene
gestellte Frage von den Lauterbach sie
haben eben gerade gesagt in der
Einführung auch schon dass sie von ihrem
bisherigen Plan im Koalitionsvertrag
absehen dass sie nur die
Kinderheilkunde dort dort nur die
Fallpauschalen rausnehmen wollen sie
haben das im Koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten auch für die
Notfallversorgung für die
Kinderheilkunde und für die Geburtshilfe
und zwar kurzfristig jetzt möchte ich
noch mal nachfragen inwiefern ihre eben
gestellte also ihren gegebene Antwort
tatsächlich der Realität entspricht
damit aber dem Koalitionsvertrag
widerspricht dass sie kurzfristig in
allen dreien Bereichen sonst noch zu
wenig aber immerhin dort die
Fallpauschalen von Fallpauschalen
absehen wollen herzlichen Dank ja vielen
Dank Herr Abgeordnete ich bitte um
Entschuldigung dass ich nicht genau
erkennen konnte ob sie verspätet
eingetroffen sind aber ich weiß ja
darauf hin dass wir in der
Kinderheilkunde die fahrpauschalen
überwinden wollen dass wir bei der
Geburtshilfe durch ein anderes System
die Geburtshilfe auf dem bayerischen
Bereich darstellen wollen dass wir die
fahrpauschalen verändern wollen in der
stationären Versorgung dass der
ambulante die ambulante Erbringung
möglich ist und dass wir das
Gesamtsystem der fahrpauschalen
dahingehend weiterentwickeln wollen oder
auch überwinden wollen dass es
vorhaltepauschalen gibt und auch andere
Elemente die da Sicherstellung der
Krankenhäuser genügen es ist also
insgesamt ein großes Programm zur
Verbesserung der Qualität in der
Krankenhausversorgung und zur
entökonomisierung es ist die größte
Reform an diesem System Seite Einführung
der farbpauschalen und wird im
Wesentlichen das jetzt bestehende System
der fahrpauschalen überwinden
ich habe jetzt wieder mehrere Nachfragen
ich hoffe jetzt nicht dass es als neue
Thema Fallpauschalen ist wir waren immer
noch bei Energieversorgung aber sie
dürfen jetzt noch eine Nachfrage stellen
ist mir unangenehm weil es in gewisser
Weise schon noch mal auf die Antwort von
der Lauterbach zurück führt ich war
nämlich nicht nur heute schon um 13 Uhr
da gewesen dass ich auch schon bei der
vereinbarungskoalitionsvertrages
zumindest habe ich ihn lesen können wenn
du schon nicht dabei war beim
Verhandlungen und dort habe ich
zumindest gesehen dass alle drei
Bereiche aus den Fallpauschalen
rausfallen sollten und zwar kurzfristig
deswegen noch mal die die Frage wollen
sie die Notfallversorgung wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart aus den
Fallpauschalen rausnehmen wie
versprochen oder nicht
ja vielen Dank Abgeordnete die
Notfallversorgung ist auch jetzt nicht
durch die fahrpauschalen abgedeckt das
ist eine Bezahlung die anders
organisiert ist und ich habe ja darauf
hingewiesen in meiner letzten Antwort
dass wir eine komplette Reform machen
für das gesamte fahrpauschalsystem was
die fahrpauschalen dahingehend
überwindet das dann eben mit
vorhaltepauschalen gearbeitet wird
sicherstellungszuschlägen und mit
einigen anderen Elementen kann ich jetzt
hier nicht also diskutieren in der kurz
in der Kürze der Zeit aber somit wurde
das bestehende fahrpauschalensystem dann
für alle Bereiche würde das überwunden
das würde die von Ihnen angesprochenen
beispielbereiche enthalten
so die nächste Frage zum Thema stellt
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
die Kollegin Weishaupt
das ist keine Sabotage hier kann sich
jeder Abgeordnete melden so und die Frau
weißer hat jetzt die Gelegenheit Ihre
Frage zu stellen vielen Dank liebe
Präsidentin lieber Herr Minister sie
haben ja gerade schon die Geburtshilfe
angesprochen jetzt würde ich da noch mal
gerne nachfragen was das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium dann auch
plant um die Gesundheitsversorgung rund
um die Geburt tatsächlich auch konkret
zu verbessern
vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für diese
Frage in der Tat in der Geburtshilfe
haben wir die Situation dass die
Kliniken die derzeit in sogenannten
sicherstellungszuschlag bekommen mit
diesem sicherstellungszuschlag alleine
die Geburtshilfe nicht so darstellen
können dass Qualität und
Versorgungsangebot gesichert sind daher
arbeiten wir an Modellen wo also hier
Zuschläge gewährleistet werden die
Ausgaben die sind sodass die
Geburtshilfe dort auch wirklich
dargestellt werden kann und dabei soll
auch unterschieden werden ob das
Kliniken sind wo eine Pädiatrie gleich
eine kinderheilkundestation gleichzeitig
vorgehalten wird oder nicht so dass wir
an qualitätsanrats geben aber das
zentrale Ziel ist dass die Kliniken die
sich alleine die Geburtshilfe nicht
erwirtschaften können aus diesem
wirtschaftlichen Druck komplett
herausgenommen werden und so unterstützt
werden dass die Sicherstellung
unabhängig von der Zahl der Geburten
gewährleistet ist dafür wäre dann der
alte sicherstellungszustellenschlag
zuständig dann eine zusätzliche
Finanzierung und eine dritte
finanzierungssäule die davon abhängen
würde ob es auch eine Geburtshilfe gibt
oder nein das ist derzeitige Stand der
Diskussion wir werden sie in kürzer
damit einem Referent mit einem
entwurfgesetzentwurf konfrontieren
sie dürfen noch eine Nachfrage stellen
und wirklich jetzt keine neuen Themen
beginnen frau Präsidentin
sie haben auf die Nachfrage verzichtet
jetzt lasse ich noch eine zu nämlich von
der FDP dann haben wir alle in dieser
Runde einmal gehabt und dann würde ich
wirklich gerne so langsam zur nächsten
angemeldeten Frage rübergehen Frau
Aschenbeck dougnos sie dürfen jetzt noch
nachfragen ursprünglich war es mal
Krankenhaus und Energiekosten
hat natürlich auch mit den
Krankenhäusern zu tun Herr Minister wir
haben ja im Koalitionsvertrag die
sogenannten hybrid-diagis vereinbart um
eben der ambulantisierung also die
ambulantisierung voranzutreiben meine
Frage geht dahingehend es gibt von Herrn
Professor Schreck aus Hamburg eine ein
Modell dass ich dadurch auszeichnet dass
es sehr schnell umsetzbar ist meine
Frage ist haben Sie das in Ihrer
Erwägung mit einbezogen und können wir
damit rechnen dass wir eben auch zeitnah
diese Hybrid die archies bekommen Vielen
Dank
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage dass Gutachten von Professor
Schreck auch im Auftrag des BMGS
erstellt ist mir natürlich bekannt und
im Rahmen der Vorbereitung der Maßnahme
Hybrid DLG wo es also darum geht dass
also zahlpauschalen
abgerechnet werden können in ambulante
Erbringung die bisher stationäre
Aufenthalte notwendig machen werden wir
dieses Gutachten berücksichtigen das
würde dann auch dazu führen dass
beispielsweise die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die sprechen von ärztlichen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die also an der
Versorgung dieser Patienten teilnehmen
wollen diese Möglichkeit bekämen wir
müssen das System öffnen so dass also
zum einen stationäre Leistung erbracht
werden können ohne
Aufenthalt in der Klinik das jetzt
Pflegekräfte frei genauer gesagt die
Pflegekräfte werden dann dort weiter
beschäftigt sind aber nicht nur
überlastet gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
auch die ambulant tätigen Ärztinnen und
Ärzten nutzen damit sie stärker in die
stationäre Versorgung eingebunden werden
können da ist dieses von Ihnen erwähnte
Gutachten sehr wichtig und das werden
wir selbstverständlich
mitberücksichtigen
nein ich habe gesagt weil wir schon sehr
weit in der Zeit sind ich gehe jetzt
weiter in der Fragestellung
weil das war noch im weitesten Sinn im
Krankenhaus aber gestatten Sie mir damit
ich jetzt weiter in die nächste Frage
gehe weil ich glaube auch bei den
nächsten Frage wahrscheinlich sehr viele
Nachfragen kommen so dass wir in der
Zeit Weiterkommen ich habe jetzt als
nächsten Fragesteller Johannes Wagner
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister welche Stellung
messen Sie dem Vorhaben bei einem
Bundesinstitut für öffentliche
Gesundheit zu errichten und wie planen
Sie mit dem Ministerium das in dieser
Legislaturperiode noch umzusetzen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter für diese
Frage in der Tat wir messen diesem
Vorhaben eine sehr große Bedeutung bei
weil der öffentliche Gesundheitsdienst
derzeit eine Einrichtung benötigt pro
zentral bestimmte Aufgaben übernommen
werden können die bisher nicht genau
koordiniert werden können zum Beispiel
Entwicklung von
evidenzbasierten Leitlinien für den
Öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienst
Entwicklung von Softwarepaketen die hier
zuständig sind
lehrmöglichkeiten also vielleicht auch
ein Studienangebot im Öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst daher hat das eine
große Bedeutung in Deutschland fehlt
eine solche Einrichtung wir wollen eine
solche Einrichtung schaffen wir planen
das also für das nächste Jahr also
bereits also wenn wir die Vorschläge
umgesetzt bekommen die Arbeiten haben
bereits begonnen wir sind dort auch im
Austausch mit der Bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche Aufklärung die
bekannterweise zumindest in Teilen in
diese Institut übergehen soll und die
Besprechungen also finden einen
regelmäßigen Abständen statt ich kann
zusichern dass wir da entsprechenden
Regierungsentwurf ihnen vorlegen können
wahrscheinlich einen ersten Entwurf auch
noch in diesem Jahr
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank sehr geehrter Herr Minister
inwiefern könnte dieses Bundesinstitut
auch dabei helfen Prävention
voranzubringen sich ein sehr prominentes
Thema im Koalitionsvertrag das hat ein
solches Institut vielen Dank für die
Frage der Abgeordneter die an solche
Institut werden natürlich für die
Stärkung der vorbeugemedizin einen Segen
das ist ganz klar weil wir in
Deutschland ein präventionsorientiertes
Bundesinstitut derzeit nicht haben viele
dieser Aufgaben werden in hoher Qualität
vom Robert-Koch-Institut mit übernommen
aber eine eigentliche
präventionsinstitution haben wir hier
nicht da ist natürlich ein solches
Institut prädestiniert hier geht es
nicht nur um
Suchtprävention sondern auch um also
verbesserte Lebensführung hier geht es
um Vermeidung von Krebserkrankungen hier
geht es um die Integration des Wissens
wie man über Kommunikation die
Präventionen also in der Bevölkerung
verbessert daher ist dieses Institut für
die Präventionsleistungen die wir uns
erwünschen einen ganz zentraler und
unabgründlicher Baustein
gibt es zu diesem Thema nachfragen
Frau Zollner
ja sehr geehrter Herr Bundesminister
meine Frage wäre sie haben jetzt auch
angesprochen dass das RKI in Teilen
Aufgaben übernimmt es gibt weitere
Institutionen und vor dem Hintergrund
dass wir überall Anspannung haben im
Finanzierungsbereich welche weiteren
Möglichkeiten sehen Sie dann weitere
Abteilungen beispielsweise in diesem
Institut zukünftig aufgehen zu lassen
und mit welchem Stellen Zuwachs rechnen
Sie gegebenenfalls bzw in der Hoffnung
dass wir dann vielleicht schlagkräftiger
werden und tatsächlich vielleicht sogar
Stellen einsparen können
ja vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage ich kann die präzise also
stellenplanung für dieses Institut jetzt
natürlich noch nicht vortragen da wir da
in der Gestaltungsphase noch sind aber
ich war will auf einen Punkt hier
hinweisen der sehr bedeutsam ist weil
sie wissen daraufhin wir müssen die
Kostenentwicklung im Auge behalten es
ist tatsächlich also ein
Manko ein Problem einen Mangel in
unserem Gesundheitssystem dass wir
bisher ein solches Institut nicht haben
durch die bessere Vorbeugung von
schweren Erkrankungen mit hohen Kosten
folgen könnten wir natürlich sehr viel
Geld einsparen daher gehe ich davon aus
dass ein solches Institut sich zum
Schluss selbst finanziert durch die
vermiedenen Kosten die durch die
verbesserte vorbaubelastung erbracht
werden können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank können wir dann davon
ausgehen dass sie zum Beispiel bei der
Akademisierung der Pflege die natürlich
auch einen großen Teil im Bereich der
Prävention tätig sein können endlich
einen Schritt weiterkommen und die
Kosten für die Ausbildung in diesem
Bereich übernommen werden analog der
Regelung der Hebammen Akademisierung
vielen Dank vorabgeordnete für diese
Frage in der Tat die also Kosten in der
akademisierten Pflege bleiben bei den
Studierenden hängen daher haben wir eine
viel zu geringe Anzahl von Studierenden
und das ist nicht hinzunehmen war
tatsächlich die Akademisierung der
Pflege dringend geboten ist wir
überlegen uns daher derzeit wie wir hier
eine Lösung finden so dass die
Studierenden entsprechend wirtschaftlich
so unterstützt werden dass sie nicht
schlechter gestellt sind als diejenigen
die in der Ausbildung sind da ist
beispielsweise eine formlösung möglich
aber ich bitte Sie um Verständnis dass
das dass ich ihnen das heute noch nicht
sagen kann auf jeden Fall werden wir das
machen dass die Studierenden in der
Pflege
gleichgestellt sind mit den
Auszubildenden
gibt es zum Thema weitere Nachfragen
ja aus der SPD-Fraktion ich kann es
nicht ganz erkennen
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr Minister
zum Institut für öffentliche Gesundheit
hätte ich gerne die Nachfrage ob sie
vielleicht noch mal kurz skizzieren
könnten warum man solches Institut auch
wichtig wäre für die Zusammenarbeit mit
den Gesundheitsämtern der Länder und
Kreise und warum das für unser
Gesundheitssystem eine gute
Angelegenheit wäre danke
ja vielen Dank vorabgeordnete für diese
Frage in der Tat wir haben wir haben
derzeit das Problem dass die
Gesundheitsämter und die öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienste wenig koordiniert
sind ich bringe ein Beispiel die
Software die verwendet wird im Rahmen
der kontaktnachverfolgung im
Pandemiefall ist nicht einheitlich und
wird auch nicht einheitlich
weiterentwickelt es gibt auch in der
Fortbildung der tätigen dort also keine
einheitlichen Leitlinien so dass zum
Teil Vorgehensweise medizinisch nicht
abgestimmt ist das ist den
Gesundheitsämtern und auch den
MitarbeiterInnen und der Mitarbeiter
gleich im Gesundheitsdienstes nicht
vorzuwerfen dort wird eine vorzügliche
Leistung gebracht ich bin dankbar dass
diese Leistung im Rahmen der Pandemie
aber nicht nur dort erbracht wurde und
möchte mich anlässlich ihrer Frage auch
bei diesen Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern hier noch einmal ganz
herzlich bedanken diese Leistung ist
sehr viel wert von ihr hängen wir ab
trotzdem müssen wir dem öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst auch hier helfen zu
einer zentralen Einrichtung zu kommen wo
Dinge gemacht werden können die einzelne
Gesundheitsämter nicht machen können
dazu zählt zum Beispiel Vorbereitung der
Lehre vor Fortbildung Weiterbildung
gemeinsame Datenpakete und dergleichen
und darüber hinaus auch die Möglichkeit
sich zu akademisieren das ist alles in
diesem Institut abgebildet daher messe
ich der also Schaffung dieses Instituts
große Bedeutung bei der Verbesserung des
öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienstes in
Deutschland bei
keine Nachfrage mehr dann gehen wir
jetzt über zum nächsten Fragesteller aus
der afd-fraktion Martin sichert
Herr Minister in der Vergangenheit wurde
ja mit der Sicherheit der Impfstoffe
sehr fahrlässig umgegangen bei Astra
Seneca beispielsweise braucht es erst
Todesfälle bis man das jungen Menschen
nicht mehr empfohlen hat bis heute haben
die Impfstoffe keine vollzulassung
sondern nur eine bedingte vorläufige
Zulassung zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen
waren allein im letzten Jahr mit
Impfnebenwirkungen beim Arzt und bis
heute kennen wir die zugehörigen
Diagnosen nicht sie machen ja immer
wieder Werbung für die Impfung daher
meine Frage an Sie wollen sie für mehr
Aufklärung und Transparenz sorgen und
einen verantwortungsvolleren Umgang mit
den Impfungen um so verlorenes Vertrauen
wiederzugewinnen
ja sehr verehrter Abgeordneter vielen
Dank für die Frage zunächst einmal
möchte ich darauf hinweisen dass ich
keine Werbung für die Impfstoffe mache
sondern ich rufe Menschen zur Impfung
auf die durch die durch die Impfung
möglicherweise vor schwerer Krankheit
und vor Tod geschützt werden und das ist
die Aufgabe eines Gesundheitsministers
und möchte auch darauf hinweisen dass
diesen Impfstoffen zahlreiche Menschen
in Deutschland ihr Leben verdienen
verdanken zum zweiten also die von ihnen
in der Frage unterstellte mangelnde
Prüfung und Sicherheit der Impfstoffe
ist wissenschaftlich nicht haltbar es
gibt überhaupt keine Impfstoffe die wir
je eingesetzt haben die so gut
untersucht gewesen sind wie die derzeit
von uns eingesetzten Corona corona- die
die Impfstoffe sind wenn ich das noch
sagen die Impfstoffe sind milliardenfach
eingesetzt worden und wir haben dabei
wir haben daher eine präzise wir haben
auf der Grundlage wir haben auf der
Grundlage des milliardenfachen Einsatzes
dieser Impfstoffe haben wir präzise
Daten zu den Nebenwirkungen dieser
Impfstoffe und auf dieser Grundlage
empfehlen die internationalen
Fachgesellschaften weltweit den Nutzung
dieser Impfstoffe vor und dem schließe
ich mich auch an
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
sie haben gerade gesagt dass es keine
Impfstoffe gab die so gut getestet sind
jetzt muss momentan das was tatsächlich
jetzt hier wozu aufgerufen wird ist ja
der ba5 im Stoff und während die
Impfstoffe am Anfang wenigstens noch an
Menschen getestet worden sind bevor man
sie zugelassen hat haben wir beim ba5
Impfstoff einen Test an 32 Mäusen gehabt
vor der Zulassung keinen Test an
Menschen halten sie wirklich 32 Mäuse
für repräsentativ für die deutsche
Bevölkerung und halten Sie das für einen
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit
Impfstoffen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete für diese
Frage die Verunsicherung der Bevölkerung
kann man so nicht stehen lassen die
die
ich entnehme ihren also Äußerungen dass
sich offenbar mit den Impfstoffen
beschäftigt haben dann wissen Sie ja
dass hier nur sehr wenige Mutationen
vorgenommen wurden dass der Impfstoff im
Wesentlichen also zu mehr als 99 Prozent
der Genomsequenz entspricht die wir also
milliardenfach eingesetzt haben daher
gibt es wissenschaftlich keinen Zweifel
daran dass das Nebenwirkungsprofil
dieser Impfstoffe dem Profil entspricht
der Impfstoffe die wir gut getestet
haben und da und daher ist es auf der
Grundlage der internationalen
Wissenschaftler nicht also der Fall wie
sie ist hier beschreiben die Impfstoffe
die wir der Sicherheit habe geprüft
haben bei den vorhandenen im Stoffen
dass diese Sicherheit lässt sich auf die
neuen Impfstoffe übertragen weil sie
gemessen am genetischen Aufbau fast
identisch ist
die nächste Nachfrage aus der
afd-fraktion Frau von Storch
ja vielen Dank Herr Minister habe ich
sie gerade richtig verstanden dass sie
gesagt haben es hat quasi noch nie an
Impfstoff gegeben der an so viel
Milliarden Menschen Fame worden ist und
damit eigentlich gut getestet worden ist
haben Sie also eigentlich gesagt dass
das Ergebnis der Prüfung das ist dass
wir jetzt in der ganzen Welt sehen
können weil man ja an so vielen Menschen
quasi getestet hat haben sie das gerade
so gesagt oder wollen sie das vielleicht
kassieren denn so haben sie es gesagt
vielen Dank für die Frage vor
Abgeordnete die Antwort ist nein
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
sie haben gerade gesagt Herr Professor
Dr Karl Lauterbach dass dieser Impfstoff
an Milliarden Menschen verimpft worden
ist weswegen die Erkenntnisse darüber
jetzt so groß sind aber vorher nicht
waren genau das haben sie gerade gesagt
wir werden das sicherlich gut
zusammenschneiden können aber vielleicht
können Sie das noch mal klarifizieren
damit die Menschen draußen im Land
erfahren dass sie möglicherweise
beteiligt waren an einem großen Versuch
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich will
es ihnen noch einmal erklären ist ich
weiß nicht ob sie es nicht verstanden
haben oder ob Sie sich hier das kann ich
wirklich nicht einschätzen ob sich hier
dümmer stellen als sie sind aber ich
werde es noch einmal erklären was ich
gesagt habe ist dass die Impfstoffe
sicher sind weil sie an sehr vielen
Menschen eingesetzt wurden nachdem sie
getestet worden und im Einsatz hat man
gesehen dass die Impfstoffe sicher sind
ich habe aber nicht gesagt dass die
Impfstoffe bei so vielen Menschen
getestet worden sind
anders anders ausgedrückt wenn aus der
aus dem Einsatz des Impfstoffes sich die
Sicherheit ergibt ist das etwas anderes
als wenn ich bei Milliarden an Impfstoff
teste
nix
die nächste Nachfrage aus der
afd-fraktion Frau Dr Baum
vielen Dank Herr Lauterbach immer mehr
Ärzte und Verbände fordern die Aufhebung
der einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
auch mehrere Bundesländer haben sich
angeschlossen und das betroffene
Personal braucht unbedingt Klarheit
deshalb frage ich im Namen vieler
Mitarbeiter haben sie vor das Gesetz
auslaufen zu lassen oder wollen Sie es
verlängern
vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage wir beschäftigen uns derzeit mit
der Entwicklung der Pandemie in der also
herbst- und winterwelle und wir werden
von dem Verlauf der herbst- und
winterwelle abhängig machen wie wir mit
der einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
umgehen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen sehr
gerne Herr Lauterbach viele Menschen
haben ihnen geglaubt und darauf vertraut
dass sie das was sie immer wieder gesagt
haben dass die Impfungen keine
gesundheitlichen Schäden nach sich zieht
und haben nun zum Teil schwerste
Nebenwirkungen wir was sagen Sie diesen
davon betroffenen impfgeschädigten es
sind auch sehr viele junge Leute unter
anderem dabei was sagen Sie dem ist
jetzt von ihrer Seite endlich mal eine
Entschuldung der Entschuldigung dazu
fällig
sehr verehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich
glaube wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein darf
dass hier eine Entschuldigung fällig
wäre von Ihrer Seite wenn Sie diese
Gelegenheit nutzen den Menschen zu
verunsichern war sie stellen es hier so
da als wenn die Impfstoffe gefährlicher
wären als sie sind in Wirklichkeit
sterben Menschen wenn sie nicht geimpft
sind und es sterben Menschen wenn sie
nicht mehr ausreichend geimpft sind und
dieser Verantwortung müssten sie gerade
als ärztliche Kollegin gerecht werden
[Applaus]
nächste
Nachfrage aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen die Kollegin Heitmann
herzlichen Dank ja Herr Professor
Lauterbach nach allem was wir wissen
senkt die Impfung ja zu dem das Risiko
auch einer long kovid-erkrankung nicht
desto trotz sehen wir leider das eine
Reihe von Menschen deutlich länger als
die fünf bis zehn Tage die man in
Quarantäne bleibt nach einer Infektion
auch damit zu kämpfen hat deshalb an Sie
die Frage was planen Sie um die
Versorgung für die an long-erkrankten
Menschen in diesem Land zu verbessern
wollen sie da speziell auch bei den
Spezialambulanzen einen Ausbau
vorantreiben und wann es genau damit zu
rechnen
ja vielen Dank vorabgeordnete für diese
wichtige Frage in der Tat das lonkovit
Problem haben wir im Auge und wir
unterschätzen es keineswegs der Ausbau
von Spezialambulanzen ist hier geplant
nicht nur an den Universitätskliniken
sondern auch in der Fläche und dabei
hinaus möchte ich ankündigen werden wir
auch uns also auf den Weg machen ein
Programm aufzulegen wo die Versorgung
mit also der Erhebung von
Forschungsdaten kombiniert wird weil wir
haben in Deutschland das Problem dass
wir die Versorgung verbessern müssen
aber gleichzeitig auch noch erforschen
müssen welche Versorgungswege die besten
Ergebnisse bringen und da werden wir
Ihnen in Kürze auch ein Vorschlag machen
können
bevor sie die Nachfrage ich sage das
jetzt noch mal die Nachfragen beziehen
sich auf die erste Frage und es kann
nicht sein dass hier andauernd neue
Themen aufgemacht werden weil sonst
kommen wir mit dieser Fragestunde und
dem Recht der angemeldeten Fragen hier
nicht weiter sie dürfen jetzt ihre
nachfragen wenn es zum gleichen Thema
ist nicht mehr Stellen ich habe die
jetzt nur nicht unterbrochen weil es war
eigentlich ein anderes Thema
auch wenn es ein wichtiges Thema ist
keine Frage aber ich bitte jetzt die ich
habe nämlich noch eine lange Liste an
nachfragen und der Ursprung der Frage
war da ging es um die Impfpflicht oder
um den Impfstoff und
Arzneimittelsicherheit um genau zu sein
das war die Ursprungsfrage
immer longkowi durchaus mit der Wirkung
der Impfung auch in Zusammenhang steht
und jetzt ist der Minister auf die
Forschung auch noch mal konkret
eingegangen und auch dafür haben wir
Geld in den Haushalt eingestellt da
würde ich gerne noch mal nachfragen wo
sie da die Schwerpunkte in der Forschung
für longcovid auch setzen möchten ja
vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage
ballonkovic ist ja zunächst einmal das
Problem dass es mehrere Krankheiten
in der Ausprägung gibt die also
nebeneinander bestehen können aber es
kann auch sein dass nur eine gibt das
sind zum einen die Krankheiten die im
wesentlichen das Gehirn betreffen also
brainfog und also Erkrankungen die
darauf hinauslaufen dass unter
bestimmten Bedingungen der Patient gar
nicht mehr arbeitsfähig ist und dann
gibt es wiederum Erkrankungen die
Treffen das Lungengewebe oder den
Kreislauf wir werden in beiden Bereichen
werden wir entsprechende
forschungsmodelle vorlegen und werden
die Spezialisierung auch so aufbauen
dass es die unterschiedlichen
Digitalisierungen gibt so dass also für
beide Bereiche sind die großen Bereiche
jeweilige Ambulanzen da sind
nächste Frage stellte aus der
afd-fraktion der Kollege Brandner
aber jetzt nicht longkowitz sondern
Ursprungsthema bitte der ursprungs-thema
selbstverständlich und um die Frage geht
es ja auch wer verunsichert wen und wer
macht Werbung für was und Herr
Lauterbach da ist mir noch im Kopf für
Ihre Äußerung von Ende letzten Jahres in
der sie prognostizierten in ihr gewohnt
sachlichen Art und Weise wie sie sowas
machen wer nicht sich wer sich nicht
impfen lässt der ist im März 2022 tot
der ist gestorben also haben sie Druck
ausgeübt das ganze sekundiert durch Jens
Spahn der sich ähnlich geäußert hat der
inzwischen für Wirtschaftspolitik
zuständig ist hoffentlich ein bisschen
erfolgreicher meine Frage noch mal sie
haben angekündigt jeder ungeimpfte ist
bis März 2022 gestorben ich bin ein
Prachtexemplar ein prachtbeispiel dafür
dass es nicht der Fall ist wie stehen
Sie zu dieser Aussage gerade vor dem
Hintergrund dass der Volksmund ja auch
sagt wer einmal lügte dem glaubt man
nicht
ja vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter
zunächst einmal ist nicht jede falsche
Einschätzung eine Lüge und zum zweiten
ist es nicht eingetroffen und war auch
aus dem Zusammenhang gerissen jetzt von
ihnen zitiert von daher ist das eine
Aussage die ich in dieser Plattenform
noch nicht getätigt habe das ist aber
es ist aber auch also wichtig also man
muss also auch also offen miteinander
umgehen können die
omegonvariante ist ja wesentlich weniger
tödlich verlaufend als sie Varianten die
wir damals gehabt haben die omikon
Variante hat damals noch niemand
vorhersehen können auch niemand in ihrer
Fraktion im übrigen und dass er dann
eine leichte verlaufende Variante mit
mehr Ansteckung aber einem deutlich
geringeren Risiko zu versterben bekommen
haben darüber können wir alle froh sein
somit wenn ich mich in der Prognose irre
weil eine Variante kommt die weniger
gefährlich ist dann bin ich dafür
dankbar und korrigiere mich gerne
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
schön dass Sie die fehlereinschätzung
einräumen aber wir gucken noch mal
zurück als sie diese Äußerung getan
haben jeder ungeimpfte ist bis März 2022
gestorben waren etwa 20 30 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland ungeimpft das an
das heißt sie als Fachpolitiker haben 20
30 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
gesagt ihr werdet sterben wenn ihr euch
nicht impfen lasst jetzt werden sich
wahrscheinlich viele ich hoffe nicht
allzu viele von ihrer Expertise haben
beeinflussen lassen die haben sich
gesunde Menschen haben sich impfen
lassen und waren danach durch die
Impfung krank ist es da nicht jetzt mal
an der Zeit sich dafür zu entschuldigen
dass sie Leute wissen nicht in Impfungen
gejagt haben die dahinter erkrankt sind
nicht an der Krankheit sondern an der
Impfung allen Folgen der Impfung
Abgeordneter ich habe das so nicht
gesagt wie es jetzt hier unterstellt
haben und von daher also kann ich auch
Ihre Frage nicht beantworten
nächste Frage zu diesem Thema aus der
afd-fraktion der Kollege Dietz
nee sie waren Siedler okay
vielen Dank Herr Minister ich habe
folgende Frage an Sie sie sagen ja die
ganze Zeit die Impfstoffe sind sicher
und sie sind verträglich und sie sorgen
dafür dass weniger Leute ins Krankenhaus
kommen ihre Staatssekretär hat heute im
Gesundheitsausschuss folgende Aussage
gemacht die
ospitalisierungsinsidenz Index liegt im
Moment bei 12 von 100.000 Einwohnern im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr zum selben
Zeitpunkt der lacht der
hospitalisierungsindex bei 1,7 erklären
Sie mir bitte wie das mit diesen
Impfstoffen einhergeht wie der
hospitalisierungsindex so ansteigen
konnte wenn denn die Impfstoffe
vernünftig wirken würden vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter für diese
Frage in der Tat ist es so dass wir
derzeit eine bedrückende Zunahme der
Patientinnen und Patienten in den
Kliniken auch auf der Intensivstation
beobachten ich habe daher eben darauf
hingewiesen dass die Länder jetzt auch
eine Pflicht sind die Maßnahmen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes zu prüfen und
anzuwenden die Tatsache dass derzeit
sehr viele Menschen erkranken weil sie
sich infiziert haben legt also an der
mangelnden Vorsicht und liegt Licht an
den Impfstoffen wenn die Impfstoffe
nicht im Einsatz wären dann würden diese
Verläufe die wir derzeit beobachten ganz
anders ausgehen das heißt wir haben im
Moment zwar eine hohe
hospitalisierungsinsidenz aber die Zahl
der Todesfälle ist deutlich niedriger
als wir sie vor einem Jahr gehabt haben
und das verdanken wir der Wirkung der
Impfstoffe
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
uns wird seit mehr als zwei Jahren
erzählt dass die Impfstoffe vor schweren
Verläufen schützen wenn man in ein
Krankenhaus kommt und diese der Index
ist deutlich höher als in den Vorjahren
dann verstehe ich nicht wie das mit
diesen
Impfstoffen überhaupt möglich ist das
ist meine Frage wieso ist das möglich
wenn die Impfstoffe so wirksam sind dass
die Leute trotzdem im Krankenhaus landen
und im Krankenhaus landen bedeutet ja es
ist ein schwerer Verlauf zumindest in
meinem logischen Verständnis das bitte
da hätte ich gerne bitte eine Erklärung
dafür vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete ich
glaube ich kann diese Frage beantworten
der Unterschied liegt darin dass es an
Unterschied macht ob ich in einem
Krankenhaus komme und werde dort
erfolgreich behandelt oder ob ich ein
Krankenhaus komme und versterbe und die
Impfstoffe die im nass werden mehr
gestorben verstaucht sie dürfen sich
nicht dümmer stellen als sie sind es mag
nicht leicht sein aber die sie die
Mädchen kommen jetzt in die
Krankenhäuser hinein und überleben die
Erkrankung weil sie geimpft sind und
wenn sie nicht geimpft wären dann wäre
der Verlauf sehr viel schwerer und es
würden mehr Menschen versterben
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen die Kollegen
Künast
Hannah ich weiß gar nicht vielleicht ist
es Dummheit oder vielleicht ist es sogar
Absicht also ich weiß jetzt nicht weil
sie gesagt haben manche stellen sich
dümmer als Sie vielleicht sind es kann
auch Absicht sein ich stelle in dieser
Runde fest wie menschenverachtend Leute
Kollegen hier sein können die mit Zahlen
operieren nach Motto es sind nicht 100
sondern nur zwölf auf der
Intensivstation ich frage mich bei
manchen was ist eigentlich in ihrem
Leben schiefgegangen dass in diese 12
Leute sowas von egal sind und im
Minister möchte ich fragen
der Minister möchte ich fragen wir reden
ja über das Impfen und die Frage der
Risiken natürlich hat jede jeder
Impfstoff auch ein Risiko andere gibt
sich aber er hat auch eine Chance und
ich würde gerne mal von Ihnen wissen wie
sie das denn abwägen Risiko und Chancen
bei Impfstoffen in Relation gesetzt zu
Risiken und Chancen wenn man nicht
geimpft ist ich persönlich kenne auch
Leute die geimpft worden und krank
wurden die lange krank sind danach aber
Verantwortung und Vorsorgeprinzip heißt
ja dass in Relation zu setzen
ja vielen Dank für Abgeordnete für diese
Frage
und in der Tat ich kann hier nur zum
Beispiel verweisen auf die Empfehlung
der Ständigen Impfkommission die den
über 60-Jährigen jetzt die
Vervollständigung des Impfschutzes
empfiehlt weil aus der Perspektive der
ständigen Informationen dort der Nutzen
der Impfung den Risiken der Impfung der
Nutzen überwiegt das Risiko der Impfung
bei weitem es ist einfach so und weil
dem so ist weil weil dem so etwas hängt
immer von natürlich vom Einzelnen ab das
Alter Spiel eine Rolle ob Risikofaktor
aber für alle über 60-Jährigen wird
jetzt beispielsweise durch die sticko
die vierte Impfung auch mit den
angepassten Impfstoffen empfohlen weil
man davon ausgeht dass für alle über
60-Jährigen der Nutzen der Impfung
größer ist als das Risiko sich impfen zu
lassen das gilt auch für diejenigen die
unter 60 sind und Risikofaktoren haben
wir haben ähnliche Einschätzungen durch
Expertenkommissionen in der ganzen Welt
also in fast allen europäischen Ländern
auch in osteuropäischen Ländern in den
Vereinigten Staaten in England diese
Empfehlungen gelten in der gesamten Welt
somit kann ich es wirklich nicht
verstehen dass die internationale
Wissenschaft hier im Haus immer wieder
hinterfragt wird ich weiß nicht woher
diese Spezialkenntnisse kommen können
keine Nachfrage ich lasse jetzt noch
zwei Nachfragen zu zu diesem Thema
auch wenn noch mehr Wortmeldungen sind
Frau von Strich lasse noch zwei zu und
ich sage auch jetzt schon dass diese
befragen zum Leidwesen des Ministers um
eine Viertelstunde verlängert wird damit
wir noch annähernd durch die
angemeldeten Fragen kommen ich habe
jetzt noch zwei einmal den Herrn
Reichert aus der afd-fraktion und dann
ist die Kollegin gleich aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion auch noch dran
ich muss da noch mal nachfragen sie
haben vorhin auf die Frage des Kollegen
sichert dass die neuen Impfstoffe mit 32
Mäusen getestet worden sind
gesagt dass das daran lege dass der
alte Impfstoff und der neue vom Genom
her zu 99% übereinstimmen nun ist es
aber auch so dass das Genom von Menschen
und Schimpansen zu 97 bis 99 Prozent
übereinstimmt ich kann da nicht erkennen
wo sie da dann diese Leichtfertigkeit
hernehmen Minister könnten sie dazu
vielleicht was sagen
sehr geehrter Abgeordneter ich glaube
das ist das also brauche ich nicht zu
beantworten die also Wirkstoffe die hier
miteinander verglichen werden das sind
ja genome die sich ausschließlich auf
die Impfwirkung beziehen und beim
menschlichen genomen wie auch beim
Schimpansen genommen und beim tierischen
genommen gibt es sehr große Strecken die
in keiner Weise beispielsweise sogar
auch nur eine funktionelle Bedeutung
haben wenn sich damit auskennen eben
Genom sind große Strecken die im
Wesentlichen also weder also die mit die
mit keiner physiologischen Eigenschaft
an hergehen somit sind diese Vergleiche
zwischen den Spezies und den Wirkstoff
von vollkommen irrelevant
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
das ist nicht der Fall dann ist jetzt
die Kollegin Borchert aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
dank frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Herr
Minister sie haben ja bereits jetzt
mehrfach erwähnt dass sie sich von der
stikobe beraten lassen sehen Sie es mir
nach dass es nicht immer der Eindruck
den ich im Gesundheitsausschuss gewinnen
konnte sie haben Aussagen zur
Auffrischungsimpfung getätigt die im
Widerspruch zur offiziellen Empfehlung
der STIKO standen warum haben sie für
diese Verunsicherung gesorgt und glauben
Sie dass dies die Impfbereitschaft
fördert und auch zu mehr Glaubwürdigkeit
für vielen Dank ja vielen Dank Frau
Abgeordnete für diese Frage wir haben
die sticko erweitert um beratende
Mitglieder so dass wir dort eine weitere
Institution ergänzend geschaffen haben
die sogenannte paiko die Pandemie
Impfkommission dieser im Kommission
wohne ich selbst bei und wir diskutieren
im Einvernehmen miteinander wir sind
keine
Missverständnisse oder
Meinungsverschiedenheiten in dieser also
Zusammenarbeit bekannt und die Arbeit
der STIKO hat einen gewohnt hohes Niveau
und jeder von uns als besonders
Ministerium voll unterstützt
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen das
das nicht der Fall dann gehe ich jetzt
über in die nächste angemeldete Frage
der SPD-Fraktion Heike Behrens
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister so wie sie und
auch andere renommierte Expertinnen und
Experten ist ja immer wieder angekündigt
haben steigen eben die
corona-infektionszahlen spürbar und die
jüngsten Entwicklungen insbesondere in
Bayern nach dem Oktoberfest führen in
den Kliniken jetzt schon zu sehr
belastenden Situationen nicht nur für
das Personal sondern vor allem auch für
die Menschen die eben in diesen
Krankenhäusern behandelt werden müssen
werden Ihrer Meinung nach die Länder
ihrer
ausführungsverantwortung im Rahmen des
Infektionsschutzes ausreichend gerecht
auch wenn Sie zum Beispiel teilweise die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht in der
Umsetzung sehr lachshandhaben und welche
ergänzenden Schritte planen Sie
gegebenenfalls für die Bundesregierung
damit wir gut durch den Herbst Winter
kommen
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage in der Tat ist es so dass
die Länder zum Teil sehr schwer
nachvollziehbare Ratschläge dann auch
öffentlich geben ich bin zum Beispiel
aus Süddeutschland zum Teil kritisiert
worden für eine nicht ausreichend
strenge Handhabung im Infektionsschutz
das ist etwas was ich eher seltener als
häufiger höre aber immerhin aber das ist
ja nicht der springende Punkt sondern
zum Talgrund an dieser Ratschläge auch
mit dem Maßkrug in der Hand vorgetragen
und hatten daher geringe Glaubwürdigkeit
ich glaube dass die Länder jetzt gut
beraten sind sich den Infektionsverlauf
genau anzuschauen das
Infektionsschutzgesetz gibt hier die
Möglichkeiten und ich glaube es ist eine
Fehlannahme zu glauben dass die jetzt
beginnen der herbst- und winterwelle
sich von alleine begrenzt das glaube ich
nicht dass der stattfinden wird daher
würde ich mir wünschen dass die Länder
jetzt prüfen wann der optimale Zeitpunkt
ist auch Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und ich
hoffe dass wir sind dann auch gut
zusammenarbeiten können davon gehe ich
aber auch aus bei der Verbesserung des
Schließens der Impflücken in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen bei den älteren
Menschen der arbeiten wir sehr eng mit
dem Hausarzt zu verbannt zusammen ich
möchte mich ausdrücklich übrigens beim
Hausarzt zuverband hier auch für die
Zusammenarbeit bei der Vorbereitung der
Impfkampagne aber auch bei der
Vorbereitung der besseren Versorgung mit
also Medikamenten bei den Betroffenen
bedanken also das ist etwas was wir
gemeinsam schaffen ich glaube wir müssen
nach vorne blicken wenn wir nach vorne
blicken Länder bunt
hausärzteschaft Pflegeeinrichtungen wir
können das schaffen wir sind besser
vorbereitet als im letzten Jahr und
haben alle Möglichkeiten
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
diese Gelegenheit nehme ich gerne war
haben wir es da sie haben vorher schon
die internationale Dimensionen der
Pandemie angesprochen und deshalb möchte
ich noch mal nachfragen wenn sie jetzt
blicken auf unseren Nachbarländer wer
hat welche Maßnahmen vielleicht besser
umsetzen können als wir und Wo können
wir uns ein Vorbild nehmen um eben
besser durch Herbst und Winter kommen zu
können
vielen Dank für die Frage vorabgeordnete
also mir liegt es fern andere Länder zu
bewerten oder anderen Ländern Ratschläge
zu geben ich glaube wir können insgesamt
mit der Art und Weise wie wir die
Pandemie bisher gemanagt haben zu
einigermaßen zufrieden sein weil wir
gemessen an zum Beispiel anderen
europäischen Ländern eine Sterblichkeit
erreichen konnten die ungefähr halb so
hoch ist somit wir sind eigentlich nicht
perfekt aber besser durch die Pandemie
bisher gekommen als viele unserer
Nachbarländer ich will einfach alles tun
was in meiner Macht steht damit es nicht
schlechter wird sondern besser
gibt es zum Thema eine Nachfrage das ist
nicht der Fall dann gehe ich zur
nächsten angemeldeten Frage die Kollegin
Katrin Vogler von aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister
ich würde jetzt gerne mal zu einem
brennenden Thema kommen auch im
Zusammenhang mit Inflation und Teuerung
ist es ja so dass wir bei der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung ein
enormes Defizit haben wo sie immer
betonen dass es im Wesentlichen von
ihrem Vorgänger geerbt ist der teure
leistungsreform gemacht hat und von
Strukturreformen Abstand genommen habe
allerdings war natürlich auch die SPD
Teil dieser Regierung und sie als
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion zuständig für
Gesundheitspolitik das heißt also dass
sie das auch ein bisschen mit zu
verantworten haben und jetzt kommt halt
leider aus ihrem Haus keine
Strukturreform die die Sicherung der
Krankenkassen nachhaltig gewährleistet
stattdessen haben sie jetzt den
Bundestag ein Notpaket vorgelegt das zum
größten Teil die Rücklagen der
krankenkassenverbraucht und das
Gesundheitsfonds dass die
beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
mindestens noch mal mit fünf Milliarden
durch beitragssatzsteigerungen belastet
und dass der GKV einen Milliarden
arbeitet von der Bundesregierung
aufzwingt wo er niemals weiß wer wieder
zurückgezahlt werden kann also da möchte
ich wissen wann ist denn sind denn jetzt
endlich von ihnen wirkliche
Strukturreformen zu erwarten
beispielsweise in dem die
einnahmensbasis der gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen verbreitert wird und mehr
Menschen mit höheren Einkommen
einbezogen werden etwa durch Anhebung
der beitragsbemessungs- und der
Pflichtversicherungsgrenze
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete ich
glaube welche Frage richtig verstehe
verwechseln Sie eine Strukturreform mit
einer Finanzreform sie haben daran nach
Strukturreform gefragt und haben dann
gesagt wann kommt denn mehr Geld ins
System aber mehr Geld ins System ist ja
keine Strukturreform die Strukturreform
das sind die Dinge die ich eben
angesprochen habe diese 12 Gesetze die
ich also eben angekündigt habe von der
Art und Weise wie wir die
Kinderheilkunde demnächst finanzieren
für die Geburtshilfe finanzieren wie wir
Anreize setzen für
tagesfahrtpauschalen wie wir das
wahlpauschalen System weiterentwickeln
wie wir die Digitalisierung durch die
elektronische Patientenakte verbessern
wie wir das elektronische Rezept
verändern wie wir die gesundheitskioske
für die Bedürftigen Bereiche machen und
so weiter das Krankenpflege
entlastungsgesetz das sind alles
Strukturreformen weil sie verbessern die
Art und Weise wie die Medizin gemacht
wird ich mache es ganz simpel bessere
und effizientere wir sehen auch durch
eine endöökonomisierung im
Krankenhaussektor das was davon
abzugrenzen ist ist die Frage wie wird
das System bezahlt die Bezahlung ist ja
keine Strukturreform und da haben wir in
der ersten Runde jetzt erstmal Effizienz
Reserven gehoben der Beitragssatz wird
darüber hinaus im 0,3 Beitragssatzpunkte
erhöht das gibt einen Steuerzuschuss von
zusätzlichen 2 Milliarden ein Darlehen
aber es ist ganz klar dass weitere
finanzierungsreformen in dieser
Legislaturperiode Folgen werden
müssen und daher also kommen die
finanzreformen aber jetzt ist erstmal
die effizienzreserve gehoben worden und
die Strukturreformen habe ich eben mit
den 12 Beispielen benannt
Möglichkeit eine Nachfrage
ja vielen Dank Herr Minister auch wenn
ich vielleicht Struktur und Finanzierung
verwechselt habe ist es doch so dass
diese 12 Reformvorhaben die Sie gerade
genannt haben werden nicht unmittelbar
zur Entlastung der beitragszahlerinnen
und Beitragszahler werden beitragen und
auch nicht dazu unmittelbar die
Versorgung effizienter und schlanker zu
gestalten sondern im Gegenteil dass die
erstmal finanziert werden müssen also
Beispiel die gesundheitskioske die sie
auch genannt haben die finde ich
tatsächlich durchaus
ein spannendes Programm wo es halt darum
geht dass gerade in ländlichen Räumen
und im benachteiligten Stadtteilen
Versorgung verbessert werden soll aber
so etwas kostet doch sie wollen tausend
Gesundheits-
ja vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete für
diese Frage die gesundheitskioske werden
insgesamt dir die GKV entlasten weil das
ja eine Versorgung in den ärmsten
Stadtteilen wo die Patienten die keinen
Zugangssystem haben oft über die
Notfallambulanzen dann aufgenommen
werden und dann oft übrigens dann sogar
stationär versorgt werden müssen hier
kann man doch durch einfache Mittel
verhindern dass eine Krankheit die durch
also kleine Interventionen noch
behandelbar ist beispielsweise in dem
die Blutdruckmedikamente eingenommen
werden zu einer schweren Krankheit der
dann stattfinde Schlaganfall wird
gesundheitskioske sind ein Beispiel
dafür wo eine neue Struktur mehr Geld
spart als was sie kostet
vielen Dank wir haben einige Nachfragen
und es beginnt der abrundesorge
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister sie haben
gerade auf die Frage des finanzdefizits
mehr oder weniger ausweichend
geantwortet und wir haben ja nun dieses
Defizit in Höhe von prognostizierten 17
Milliarden Euro fürs nächste Jahr die
nächsten Jahre dann voraussichtlich
sogar noch höher und deshalb meine Frage
sie haben ja in der Vergangenheit
ausgeschlossen dass quasi 10 Milliarden
die im System ja fehlen weil die
Beiträge die Krankenkassenbeiträge für
alg2-bezieher aus dem Bundeshaushalt
nicht in ordnungsgemäßer Höhe abgeführt
werden in den gesundheitsformen dass Sie
darauf verzichten werden das heißt sie
Unternehmen überhaupt nicht den Versuch
beim Bundesfinanzminister die Mittel die
ja dem Gesundheitssystem zustehen wird
in Höhe von 10 Milliarden dort
einzufordern und deshalb würde mich
interessieren ob sie ernsthaft glauben
dass sie diese 17 Milliarden Defizit mit
Effizienz Reserven im System so wie sie
es ja immer sagen
ja kompensiert bekommen und gleichzeitig
die Akteure im System Ärzte apothe
Pharmaindustrie forschende Unternehmen
zusätzlich belasten wollen
ja vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter
zunächst einmal möchte ich noch einmal
darauf hinweisen dass ich dieses Defizit
bekanntlicherweise von meinem Vorgänger
geerbt habe zum zweiten sie werden sehen
durch den abstimmungsverlauf sie werden
sehen durch den abstimmungsverlauf hier
im Haus dass wir dieses Defizit
bereinigen können durch das Heben von
Effizienzreserven und zum dritten ich
habe nicht gesagt dass ich also auf die
Erhöhung der Beiträge für
Arbeitslosengeld 2-empfänger oder die
Dynamisierung des Bundeszuschusses dass
ich darauf verzichten werde aber nur bei
einer Veranstaltung darauf hingewiesen
dass du das jetzt nicht machen müssen
sondern dass das im Laufe der
Legislaturperiode stattfinden muss aber
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt können wir das
bestehende Defizit beheben durch die
Effizienzreserven die im System noch
bestehen und das werden sie quasi der
Abstimmungsergebnisse hier im Haus bald
sehen
gibt es noch eine Nachfrage
natürlich habe ich noch eine Nachfrage
dazu das ist ja im Grunde das Herr
Minister was sie die letzten Monate
quasi mantraartig vor sich her tragen
dass sie sagen alle Probleme die das
Gesundheitssystem in Deutschland hat
hätten sie von ihrem Vorgänger geerbt
also es ist ja bereits schon angeklungen
oder ich kann mich dunkel erinnern dass
sie in der letzten Legislatur ja als
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
ja ja das tut weh ja tut weh ich weiß
dass sie als Stellvertreter
Fraktionsvorsitzender ja für den
Gesundheitsbereich zuständig waren und
insofern insofern würde mich schon mal
interessieren ob der damalige
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz und
jetzige Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz der
diese 10 Milliarden immer gedeckelt hat
und nicht abführen wollte ob Sie der
Meinung sind dass das richtig war
ja vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete ich habe
nie gesagt was soll ich meine Meinung
dass man Vorgänger alles falsch gemacht
hat das ist nicht meine Meinung und das
würde ich auch nicht vortragen aber
lediglich auf dieses Defizit hier
abgehoben und das werde ich beseitigen
mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im
Haus zusammen dann das werden wir durch
Effizienz Reserven beseitigen und wie es
dann durch mit der weitergehenden
Finanzierung unseres Gesundheitssystems
sich entwickelt das werden wir im
nächsten Jahr dann gemeinsam entwickeln
wir werden also die Strukturreformen
machen die 12 Gesetze die ich eben
beschrieben habe wir werden eine
Finanzreform machen und wir werden das
Defizit beseitigen es wird alles
gelingen also an allen drei Blöcken
werden wir erfolgreich arbeiten also
Effizienz Reserven
Strukturreformen und Finanzreform alle
drei Blöcke werden abgearbeitet und zwar
erfolgreich
dann habe ich eine Nachfrage der Kollege
Lüdke
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister natürlich hängt
es Defizit in der Krankenversicherung
auch mit den Versäumnissen bei
Strukturreformen da Vorgängerregierungen
zusammen ich bin deswegen sehr froh dass
wir diese jetzt endlich angehen was
genau haben Sie vor um die
ambulantisierung voranzutreiben und
welche Rolle sollen niedergelassene
Ärzte und andere therapieberufe in dem
Zusammenhang spielen ja vielen Dank Frau
Abgeordnete für diese Frage in der Tat
wir wollen in der im Bereich der
stationären Versorgung etwas einführen
was in vielen anderen europäischen
Ländern schon gelungen ist dass die
fahrpauschalen Leistung also die
Leistung die stationär erbracht wird
dass sie auch erbracht werden kann in
dem auf die Übernachtung verzichtet wird
das kann man mit dem Begriff tagesdealg
beschreiben auf jeden Fall führt das
dazu dass dort massiv bei der Pflege
entlastet werden kann man kann
allerdings auch Leistungen die bisher
stationär erbracht worden komplett
ambulant erbringen und da sind natürlich
auch die niedergelassenen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen gef und dass sie sich dort
einbringen sie alle kennen den
aop-katalog da könnte man sich
vorstellen dass wir diesen Katalog der
ja vorliegt stärker ausweitend in die
Versorgung einbringen wir können es uns
nicht länger leisten dass wir die
ambulanten und die stationären Bereiche
gegeneinander stellen sondern hier muss
miteinander gearbeitet werden das
verbessert die Effizienz der Versorgung
die Versorgungsqualität und das auch die
einzige Art und Weise wie wir den Mangel
in der Zukunft begegnen können haben sie
eine Nachfrage
Stellungnahme der Regierungskoalition
Kommission zum Bereich die jetzt
vorliegt zum Bereich ambulantisierung
ist das für sie ein gangbarer Weg die
Maßnahmen die dort aufgezeigt worden
sind die Stellungnahme der
Regierungskommission ist von uns mit
großem Wohlwollen aufgenommen worden und
das was wir in den nächsten Monaten
entwickeln werden die Arbeit hat ja
längst begonnen wird sich also sehr eng
an dem orientieren was die
Regierungskommission vorgetragen hat es
sind ja immer mehrere Optionen auch
vorgetragen worden wir werden die Option
wählen die politisch am besten und am
effizientesten durchsetzbar ist
so das war die doch sehr interessante
Befragung der Bundesregierung mit dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister mit Karl
Lauterbach gegen 15 Uhr melden wir uns
hier wieder wenn es dann eine Aktuelle
Stunde gibt zu den Vorschlägen der
Expertenkommission zur gaspreisbremse
jetzt geht's aber erstmal weiter mit
meiner Kollegin Ines Arland in Bonn